دعونا نتخيل
الوباء التالي ، حسنًا ، لقد بدأ
وكثير من هؤلاء بدأوا في مكان ما
في آسيا ربما في شرق آسيا
لمجموعة متنوعة من الأسباب ،
ما هي خطة بيل غيتس ، ما
الذي تود أن يحدث عندما تكون أول
مرة
في المرة الأولى  تسمع عن
إصابة بعض الأشخاص بنوع من
الفيروسات المحمولة جواً ،
نعم الخطر الكبير هو
فيروس الجهاز التنفسي
الذي ينتقل عن طريق الإنسان ، وتريد أن يكون لديك مجموعة
متصلة بمنظمة الصحة العالمية
ترى هذا التفشي
مبكرًا
وتكون قادرة على الدخول والبحث
تسلسل ما هو فهم
لطبيعة ذلك ،
يحتوي على بعض الأدوات التي لا تعتمد
على مسببات الأمراض المحددة التي يمكنك منح
الناس ليس فقط الأقنعة ولكن أيضًا بعض
الأدوية لمنع انتقال العدوى
وتريد إيقافها قبل أن تصل
إلى العديد من البلدان التي  عندما
يصبح الأمر وباءً مزعومًا ، يجب عليك
القضاء عليه في مهده وهذه
الأشياء متسارعة ، لذا فإن
تجنب الحالات التي تعرفها هنا يوفر الكثير
من الحالات في نهاية المطاف  هذه
المجموعة وتسمى جرثومة
إنها أه تشرح الاختصار ما هو
نعم هذا الوباء العالمي أه
الاستجابة ومجموعة الجراثيم
أه يديرها من وتعتقد أنها
ستكلف حوالي مليار دولار
سنويًا لذا لا استثمار ضخم لا  أنت
تعلم أنه ضئيل جدًا مقارنة
بالأرقام التي تحدثنا عنها مع
ميزانيات الدفاع أو تغير المناخ أو ما
لدينا من إنفاق طبي على kovid
من حيث الإغاثة التي كان علينا أن نقدمها للناس من أجل
عمليات الإغلاق التي كانت في التريليونات ،
نعم نحن 14  تريليون من الأضرار الاقتصادية
واه لا تزال تحسب لذلك
فهي واحدة من أرخص
بوالص التأمين عليك
التأكد من بقاء الناس بدوام كامل
آه جعلنا نتدرب والممارسة
وهو أمر صعب بالنسبة للأشياء التي لا تأتي.
غالبًا ما تعرف مع
الزلازل أنه من الجيد تقريبًا
أنها صغيرة أو حرائق
صغيرة لأنها تذكرك دائمًا ،
قد يكون هناك زلزال كبير
من حيث انتشار المرض عالميًا لا
يحدث  ح لكنه سيحدث أكثر
إما كما تقول إن آسيا تشكل خطرًا كبيرًا في
إفريقيا ، إنها أيضًا مخاطرة كبيرة لأن
الحدود بين البشر
والحيوانات تقترب أكثر فأكثر